welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and wandavision's latest full
trailer finally began to reveal its
darker secrets and what i have been
referring to as the
back nine of these trailers once you get
past those goofy nostalgic sitcom
homages designed to
hook i suppose the core tv land
demographic what the devil is really
going on here
not today mephisto apparently no one
wants to hear how evil is
everywhere you look
one detail that was confirmed in this
one division trailer and other disney
investor day marvel footage
was something we have speculated for a
while a return
to sokovia in the mcu in the breakdown i
discovered that the penultimate shot of
wanda with the mind stone was a
recreation of wanda's past
as an inmate in that sokovian hydra base
which we saw in that post-credits scene
of 2014's captain america winter soldier
but folks there are
more sightings of wanda's sokovian pass
hidden in this trailer i gotta break it
down for you guys along with maybe
a clue pointing to the return of
quicksilver picture maximoff aaron
taylor johnson
in this show and i'm gonna explain why
this is so important to how the mcu
moves forward beyond wandavision okay
the trailer ends with this interesting
close-up of wanda basking in the yellow
glow of the mind stone now a few things
tell us this is taking place
in her sokovian captivity wanda's look
she's pale she's got string hair
gray clothes just like she had in that
scene then there's the fact that this
mine stone first appears to be in a blue
casing as the mind stone was when it was
contained in loki's scepter and you can
briefly make out her surroundings she's
in this windowless room with an
observation mirror like ones that you
could imagine von strucker and dr list
looking at her through this all confirms
that wanda will in some kind of
flashback return to that moment her
powers were activated in that hydra base
wanda and pietro got their powers from
the mine stone in the scepter but that
process was left
super vague part of the reason is that
in the marvel comics wand and pietro are
mutants whose powers emerged through
different means way earlier in their
lives both were children of eric lyncher
magneto and wanda as a child was cursed
by the demon chithon
leaving her with the sorcery in the form
of scarlet tinted chaos magic manger's
age of ultron was legally prohibited
from exploring that backstory because
the rights to these characters as
mutants were technically owned by fox
then a rival studio so that movie had to
awkwardly refer to them as
enhanced not anymore though disney owns
everything and now we've been getting
these little signs
like passages and mcu companion books
that wanda pietro and
other sokovians were born with genetic
predispositions that made them more
agreeable test subjects for the mind
stones radiation in other words marvel
can say scarlet witch and quicksilver
were always mutants just with dormant
powers but the mind stone's radiation
just
accelerated and woke up and speaking of
radiation using a uv light to scan for
crucial mcu details in a book
is it really how most marvel fans want
to experience these stories
so now it appears one division will show
us that origin story and how it went
down exactly and this backstory appears
to be important to
everything wanda is experiencing in the
series because here is the big detail
something i spotted in the breakdown but
did not fully appreciate the
significance of
when wanda's 60s home glitches and
transforms around her on her dining room
wall briefly
appears to be this mural of a
mountainside building a colorado hotel
turns out nope this is fort bard aka
the film setting of the hydra research
base in sokovia
in avengers age of ultron so wanda's
past and sokovia
is calling to her an unexplored trauma
and grief
over the brother she lost in that
country now
haunting her present reality with her
grief from losing vision
tearing back open all the grief she
tried to bury
so does a flashback to sokovia mean
pietro maximoff quicksilver aaron taylor
johnson will appear on this show
is he already in this trailer but before
i continue thank you to
bang energy for sponsoring this video
sweet every can of bang is 16 ounces it
contains 300 milligrams of caffeine it's
sugar-free and it has zero calories
yet it tastes real great
there's over 20 different flavors to
choose from one of those great flavors
is
bangster berry a berry that i presume
due to mandatory sentencing laws
probably went to jail for a long time
because being a bankster
doesn't pay but it does make a delicious
energy drink check out bang on instagram
you can get
25 off your order at bang energy.com
when you use the code newrockstars25
there you can buy cans of bang
energy they got a sweet tea flavor they
got a keto coffee flavor
you can also get clothing or fitness
supplements all kinds of stuff to be
your best bang so
thanks again to bang energy for
sponsoring this video get 25
off at bang energy.com using the code
new rockstars 25.
another interesting thing about this
mine stone shot in the wanavision
trailer is the fact that the stone
appears to burst out of its blue casing
floating in the air at wanda's eye level
not appearing to be in the scepter when
ultron plucked that stone out of the
scepter it was a big deal but now it
seems like this stone could go in and
out and in and out of that thing
that the stone was lifted from the
scepter house scene before that
transplant to what would eventually
become vision's android forehead and if
you look closely beneath the yellow glow
in the over-the-shoulder shot of wanda
when it appears to blow her back
there is something on the table in front
of her it looks like a box or a
container of some kind and maybe this is
the way dr list and von strucker exposed
wanda to that radiation they couldn't
weaponize it in the scepter but they
could just throw that radioactive rock
in the room with her but the reason why
all those other test subjects failed is
that this stone made a connection with
wanda of all the six stones the mind
stone
is the smart one it's got an inner
intelligence to it it spoke to vision
and here i think it's selected wanda to
transfer its power to her this is
important because in wanda's eyes you
can see
two sets of glowing objects one
presumably from the stone the much
brighter one
the other maybe it's just a production
light source but if they focused on her
eyes so much there are clearly two
things glowing there
is something or someone else in that
room receiving a glow for the mind stone
wanda's brother pietro either way we see
that stone blowing wanda back with a
violent force
similar to the infinity stone radiation
shockwave that struck carol danvers and
captain marvel the scene geography of
that post-credits scene suggests that
just on the other side of wanda's wall
is her brother so whatever blast hits
her
here could have also hit her brother it
might even be the case that the mind
stone
only selected wanda but that accident
that caused her to be irradiated also
caught pietro in the blast
and it was just fortunate that he had a
similar dna structure that allowed both
of them to survive it in a way
wanda's inciting incident would have put
her brother
on his doomed path further
contextualizing her grief as
survivor's guilt she feels like she's
got blood on her hands making the mind
stone
her curse and this cosmic link keeps
getting
all the men she loves killed and while
wanda carries this guilt with her
and we will see the vulnerable attempts
that she makes to right those wrongs via
sitcom inspired projected realities in
one division
of course none of this is truly wanda's
fault she is being used and we know this
from that moment with jimmy woo's voice
coming over the radio
into that reality telling us that wanda
is a victim
and i've talked at length about the
various dark forces that could be
actively manipulating her from the
outside this detail returning to sokovia
tells us that this show
will rewind the clock to the beginning
to answer that question
what is going on inside wanda and now
that marvel studios can freely explore
things like mutant history
and the x gene in the mcu i'm guessing
we're gonna hear
words like that in these flashbacks
along with hopefully
a reference to the paternity that
bestowed these genetic miracles upon the
twins coming from eric lyncher
magneto even if it's in the form of a
birth certificate with the space for
father marked with just the letter x
i'll take it i'll make a thousand videos
about it give me that x swan division
one division premieres on disney plus
january 15th and in addition to in-depth
easter egg breakdowns for each episode
we will be doing same day
after shows go ahead the podcast is
there inside marvel a one division after
show
more details to come folks support this
channel by checking out our great merch
options at nurocstarsmerch.com follow me
at eavos follow new rockstars thanks for
watching boom
[Music]
you